hi everyone i'm joris a cloud technical
resident at google cloud
and i'm lydia a customer engineer at
google cloud
and welcome back to the technical guide
for startups where we are creating a
series of videos for technical
enablement to start building grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on google cloud
in our previous episode we share with
you how to build stream processing
pipelines with data flow
today we are moving to our seventh stop
which is data visualization using data
studio we are going to kick off by
covering an overview to the data life
cycle what is data studio how it works
and the building blocks before jumping
into a demo to see how to create reports
and finally we'll share a status success
story that use data studio to grow their
business
so come on let's go ahead to explore
data visualization
but first let's have an overview of the
data lifecycle as most of the companies
and businesses manage the data the same
way
the first phase is to pull in the raw
data such as streaming data from devices
on-premises batch data app logs or
mobile apps user events
then it's important to clean and
transform the data before storing it
into a format that is durable and that
can be easily accessed
you can check the documentation to
choose between a structure or
unstructured storage and relational
non-relational databases
after data is ingested stored and
processed it needs to end up in a format
that lets it be easily accessed and
query to be analyzed and get insights
during the analysis phase you might find
it useful to generate complex data
visualizations dashboard and reports to
better understand and explain the
results of the data processes to a
broader audience to make this easier
google cloud integrates with a number of
reporting and dashboarding tools such as
looker vi engine and data studio note
that when analyzing data across your
organization data governance is
essential so looking ahead we will
further integrate looker with data
studio so you can govern your data from
one central location in looker and build
visualizations in data studio if you
want to learn more about the integration
between looker and data studio please
refer to the links in the description
so
what is data studio
well data studio is a tool that turns
your data into informative easy to read
easy to share and fully customizable
dashboards and reports data studio's
vision as a product is to simplify the
critical steps in producing reports and
dashboards all you have to do is 1.
connect to all your data
data studios built-in connectors make it
possible to connect to virtually any
kind of data
2. visualize with beautiful and
informative reports turn your data into
compelling stories of data visualization
art
quickly build interactive reports and
dashboards with data studio with base
reporting tools
and three share your reports and
dashboard with individuals teams or the
world you can collaborate in real time
and even embed your report on any
website
so how do we start what are the blocks
and the pieces that connect everything
together
what we will need first is the data
collected the data set are the files or
the tables outside of data studio where
your collected data actually resides
to start visualizing that data it needs
to be imported into data studio
connecting to your data involves two
components that work together
the data source and the connectors
connectors connect your data to data
studio connecting your data creates a
data source in data studio so basically
a data source is an instance of a
connector therefore data studio use data
sources to build and create reports
these data sources let you configure the
fields and options provided by the
connector used to create that connection
instance in addition data sources let
you share information and insight with
report viewers who might not be able to
directly access your underlying data
and so last piece is the report
the report is the visualized content
from the data source
reports lets you visualize your data
gain insights and share those insights
with others as mentioned data studio
allows you to connect to different data
sources quickly and easily
no more exporting into excels to upload
into a reporting tool or refreshing your
data sets to make sure your reports are
up to date data is natively integrated
and is directly based on the underlying
data sets making updates super simple
you can connect to over adults in google
products for instance you can add
analytics data to your dashboards to
analyze and measure the performance of
your website or mobile apps you could
also include google ads data to your
dashboard to measure the performance of
your digital marketing
or even add bigquery data to your
dashboard to analyze the data from your
data warehouse or to visualize your key
business metrics
in addition the community connector
program gives you virtually access to
any internet connected data set
all you need is a developer and an api
you can check all new connectors in the
description links and as you can see
creation is a snap so as soon as your
data sources are connected you can
create multiple variations of charts as
well as facebook designs and brands
reports can consist of multiple pages
charts or other components such as
controls text areas shapes and images
the interface consists of an editor with
drag and drop functionality with click
to change dimensions metrics or even
data sources themselves
so this is built for anyone to
self-service
and of course you can share reports for
people to view the data or even give
them edit access so they can change the
structure
so let's see a real example
thank you lydia now we are ready to jump
on the data studio demo let's now take a
look at data studio in action
first i start by going on the data
studio homepage at datastudio.google.com
before we start building with data
studio i want to show you some
dashboards from data studios template
gallery
these dashboards come in handy if you
want to start from a pre-made dashboard
and amend it to your use case if you're
just looking for inspiration to make a
dashboard from scratch
first we'll take a look at the youtube
analytics dashboard that is available
here
here at the top there is a control that
allows you to choose your data
in other words you can just start from
this template
simply plug your data into it to have
your own customized dashboard that you
can directly share with your
stakeholders
this dashboard contains several metrics
such as number of views average watch
time and so on
it is fully interactive when i hover on
the chart i can see the data points and
labels
i can also click on a specific country
here the united states to see the data
for this country only
let's now take a look at another
dashboard this one is made from google
analytics data
here at the top i can filter the data by
region channel and more
on this page i have several charts that
allow me to track relevant metrics and
derive insights
next i want to show you the dashboard
that we will be using as a baseline for
our demo
it shows site sessions page views across
different countries channels and
demographics
following the demo you will be able to
start using data studio and build such
dashboards in a few minutes
let's now wait any longer and jump right
into the demo
back on the data studio home page i can
see the data sources and reports that
i've recently used
i can also filter this list to see only
the reports and data sources that i own
to create a report i can either create a
data source first then repo later or
create a report first then add the data
source to it
to create a data source click on create
data source then choose a connector
let me choose google sheets here
then select the spreadsheet i want to
use then click on connect
on this page i can see the dimensions
and metrics of my data source
it's also possible to change data types
and default aggregation methods
at the top i can choose the data
credentials from my data source owner's
credentials allow anyone using this data
source to access the underlying data set
using the credentials of the owner of
this data source
viewer's credentials require anyone
using this data source to use their own
credentials to access the underlying
data set
on this page i can also see the data
freshness of the data
note that some connectors allow to
update the frequency of the update more
information in the description
if i want to create a report
i can just click on create report here
at the top
however i already have a data source
from which i want to create a report for
today
let me then go back to the seo home page
click on create
report then select the my data sources
tab
then the sample google analytics data
as you can see a table has been added
automatically i will remove it to
include my own custom charts
let's answer some business questions
using data studio
first i would like to know the countries
with the most sessions
i will include a jio chart to find it
out
i go to add a chart then click on the
geochart then select session as a metric
now i will use a table to display the
number of sessions and page views per
country
i can add the relevant metrics by
clicking on add a metric
then selecting the desired matrix
next i will change the table style as i
want page views to show as a bar instead
of a number
using the style tab you can easily
customize your charts to look as you
like
let me then go to the style tab then in
the matrix column 2 section i can change
from number to bar
it is also possible to change the color
of the balls from here
next i also want a different color for
the geochart again using the style tab
it is straightforward
data studio also comes with themes
helping you to maintain consistent
formatting across your report
to pick a theme simply go to theme
layout then pick the one you like
of course you can also create your own
custom themes to match your
organization's branding for example more
information and themes in the
description box
now that we have charts we need to
add text to bring more context so that
we can share our insights easily with
our team
for that
i will use the text box to add a title
what are the tab countries for sessions
then i can format it using the style tab
i can just copy paste and edit this
title before answering my next business
questions which is
hawa site sessions trending over time
this time i will go for a time series
chart
first let me add the session count as a
metric
next i want to compare that to the
previous period
in order to do so simply select previous
period from the comparison date range
section
now i will change the style of this time
series change the color
and then go to the legends section to
center the legend and put it at the
bottom
next i'm interested in finding the
channels that are driving the engagement
to find that out i add a bar chart then
select default channel grouping as a
dimension
then session and page views as metric
and then change the style of the balls
to fit my needs now i want to show you
how to enable cross filtering
first click on a chart and enable cross
filtering in the chart interaction
section
i will do it for the bar chart and geo
chart
note that cross filtering is now on by
default for most data source types
and now the cool thing is that when i
click on the channel on a country the
whole dashboard immediately updates
accordingly to reflect the data
corresponding to those filters
here i choose to focus on the united
states
let me go back to the original setting
by clicking the reset button on the top
another way setting up filters
is using controls i want to use the
range control for that i click on other
control
then date range control and place it
wherever i like on my report
you can pre-select the given time range
however i'll keep the auto-date range
setting for today
let me now filter the data to a specific
time range to see how the report updates
what about comparison metrics i would
like to know the proportion of each
country when it comes to the number of
sessions
i will include a comparison calculation
to our table to find that information
first i click on add a metric
then select sessions then click on the
pencil icon to edit the metric
and in a comparison calculation field i
choose percent of total related to base
data
note that you can also include running
calculation to your tables and shots
and now i can see that 46
of my sessions are taking place in the
united states
oh i just remember that my teammate told
me they would have been nice to have the
average number of page views per session
therefore i'm creating a custom field by
clicking on add a metric
create field
setting up the name to be average page
views procession and then in formula i
type
page views divided by stations data
studio finds the metric as i type them
we're done on that one
of course you can also add other pages
simply by clicking on add a page and
then adding your tables and shots to
that newly created page
okay we have done quite some good work
today let's take a look at our dashboard
clicking on view here at the top
looks great now we can share our report
with others schedule email delivery
get a link to the dashboard or even
download it
what if you want to collaborate with
teammates on building a dashboard
well data studio comes with
collaborative editing allowing multiple
people to work on the same dashboard
at the same time so as you can see it's
super easy to work with data studio and
that's why many customers use it to grow
their businesses
one of them is fairy god boss a us-based
company that has been founded to create
a space where women can cross-source
information to make informed career
decisions
so they state that after seamlessly
connecting bigquery data to data studio
they have been able to visualize in real
time and make sense of all the data they
receive in the platform thank you for
taking a quick tour of data studio with
us today we've seen where it fits in the
daily life cycle how it works and how it
helps you to share the value of your
data across your organization
if you're looking for a tool to analyze
your data
quickly and easily build dashboards and
share insights with your teams
well data studio is a solution for you
and your organization
want to find out more
please refer to the links in the
description to read more about data
studio use our ready to use templates
try the online course or even learn more
about local
looking ahead data studio is integrating
with lucr to bring the best of
self-serve and govern business
intelligence looker's semantic model
allows metrics to be centrally defined
and broadly used making sure there is
only one version of the truth across all
of your data
if you're loving data studio but you're
starting to recognize the importance of
data governance you may want to take a
look at looker if you want more
information please check the description
box
that's a wrap for today
our next video in this series will
introduce you to our machine learning
apis so you can get even more value from
your data
for now don't forget to like the video
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click on the bell icon to get notified
each time a new video is posted
thank you again for being here today
stay tuned and we'll see you very soon
in the next video
[Music]